loud speaker really works okay thank you
all very much for coming out today
I don't often use the phrase but today
we are in fact offering a revolutionary
proposal a proposal that will transform
and improve our country in many many
ways and a highly competitive global
economy when we need the best educated
workforce in the world
this proposal will make it possible for
every person in America to get all of
the education they need regardless of
their financial status this means not
only a college education but the right
to enter a trade school the right to
learn how to become a carpenter or a
plumber or a sheetmetal worker and get
one of the many important jobs that keep
our society going in other words we will
make a full and complete education a
human right in America to which all of
our people are entitled this means
making public colleges universities and
HBCUs tuition-free and debt-free by
tripling the work-study program
expanding Pell grants and other
financial incentives today we are
entering a proposal which will allow
every person in this country to get all
of the education that they need to live
out their dreams because they are
Americans further in the wealthiest
country in the history of the world it
is simply not acceptable that our
younger generation through no fault of
their own will have a lower standard of
living than their parents more debt
lower wages and less likelihood of
owning their own homes that is why this
proposal completely
eliminate student debt in this country
and ends the absurdity of sentencing an
entire generation the millennial
generation to a lifetime of debt for the
crime of doing the right thing and that
is going out and getting a higher
education ten years ago the United
States government bailed out Wall Street
after their greed their recklessness and
the illegal behavior drove us into the
worst recession in modern history today
the major Wall Street banks are larger
than ever their profits are soaring and
their CEOs receive huge compensation
packages our proposal which costs 2.2
trillion over 10 years will be fully
paid for by a tax on Wall Street
speculation similar to what exists in
dozens of countries around the world the
American people bailed out Wall Street
now it is time for Wall Street to come
to the aid of the middle class of this
country this Wall Street tax will have
the added benefit of controlling Wall
Street recklessness and reducing the
likelihood of another major economic
crash in 1944 his World War two was
coming to an end the US government did
the right thing and passed the GI Bill
which made high up education free to all
of those who served in the armed forces
that act not only improved the financial
well-being of millions of men and women
but it also laid the groundwork for a
great expansion of the American middle
class in the 1960s and 1970s the federal
government and state governments
invested heavily in higher education
with the result that college tuition was
virtually free virtually free for
millions of young people 40 years ago a
federal pell grant paid
nearly 80% of tuition fees room and
board at a four-year college well
unfortunately things have changed over
the years and changed in a bad way today
it will cost over $21,000 each and every
year to attend some of these very same
schools which fifty years ago were
virtually free today Pell grants cover
only 30 percent of college expenses and
here are the results of federal and
state higher education cutbacks today
the average college senior graduates
with about $30,000 in student debt and
one out of six seniors will graduate
with all about $50,000 in debt the
situation is even worse for African
American and Latino families and at a
time when we desperately need more
doctors and dentists and nurses those
who are graduating medical school in
dental school in nursing school finding
themselves in some cases with three or
four hundred thousand dollars in debt
and here is a sad truth another sad
truth regarding this whole crisis many
students are dropping out of college not
getting their degrees and yet they still
find themselves with tens of thousands
of dollars in debt let's be clear the
millennial generation was told that the
only way they would get the good jobs
available is if they received a college
education unfortunately that turned out
to be bad advice it was wrong since 2000
the cost of attending of public college
has nearly doubled meanwhile the bottom
60% of college graduates earn less money
than those who graduated college did 19
years ago and wages for the average
college graduate have stagnated today 34
percent of Americans 25 and older have a
college degree but only 20
6% of them in our country 26% of those
crops require a college education the
result is that many millions of young
people today are forced to work at low
wage jobs their standard of living is
going down while they are struggling to
pay off
they are outrageously high level of
student debt bottom line is we should
not be punishing people for getting a
higher education it is time to hit the
reset button under the proposal that we
introduced today all student debt would
be canceled in six months by taking this
action by taking this action we not only
provide immediate financial relief to 45
million Americans who have one point six
trillion in debt but we will be
improving the entire economy according
to a recent study canceling all student
debt would add an estimated one trillion
dollars for our economy over the next
decade and create up to 1.5 million drop
let me just conclude by giving you a
tale of two crises ten years ago because
of their greed and illegal behavior Wall
Street banks were on the verge of
collapse and the United States Congress
with taxpayer assistance came to their
eight
well now we got millions and millions of
families in this country who are
struggling with outrageous levels of
student debt and maybe instead of just
worrying about Wall Street we start
worrying about those families and that
generation and give them a break so this
is for those families this is for those
young people this is for the economy and
this is for justice and that is what we
are proposing thank you all very much
[Applause]